one problem 55
55. at a certain picnic each of the
guests was served either a single scoop
or a double scoop of ice cream
how many of the guests were served a
double scoop of ice cream so let let's
say that d
is the number of guests that were served
double scoop and that's what we're
trying to figure out so what are their
statements
statement number one
says
at the picnic sixty percent of the
guests were served a double scoop of ice
cream so sixty percent of the total were
served double scoop let's see if we can
write that algebraically
so sixty percent of the guests
so sixty percent
of the guests
so the guess the total number of guests
are the are the number of guests that so
that were served double scoops
plus the number of guests that were
served single scoops then we have all of
the guests right
this is this is equal to the total
number of guests
and they tell us that sixty percent of
them were served double scoop so the
number that served were served double
scoop is sixty percent of the total so
that statement number one is just an
algebraic equation and this alone though
doesn't help me solve this equation
maybe in the next statement they'll tell
us how many total guess there are what
this is and that'll help me but i don't
know let's see statement number two
statement number two
they say a total of 120 scoops of ice
cream were served to all the guests at
the picnic
so once again they're telling us that
they're 120 scoops of ice cream they're
not telling us that they're 120 guests
so let's see what are the total number
of scoops so there's the number of
single scoops and each of those are
the number of guests that got single
scoops are s and then the number of
scoops is just one times that because
each got one scoop
and then you have the number of guests
that got double scoops but then the
number of scoops they got is going to be
two times that
so this is a total number of scoops
right the number of people who got
single scoops types one plus a number
that got double scoops times two and
that is going to be equal to the total
number of scoops
and this alone isn't going to help us
solve how many double scoops were served
depends on the single scooped and all of
that but if you look at both of these
statements we have two linear equations
in two unknowns so
at this point you should immediately say
unless somehow these are
you know the same equation
or they don't or somehow these are two
parallel lines these should intersect
and come up with um and allow you to
solve this equation so the answer you
should immediately if you especially if
you don't want to waste time you should
say that both statements together are
sufficient and if you want me to prove
this to you let me see if i can solve
this
so i'll do a different color
so let me do some let me do some
substitution so we here we get s is
equal to
120 minus 2d
and we can substitute this back here so
you get 0.6 times d
plus
s which is 120
minus 2d
is equal to d
and so you get
see 0.6 times 120
minus d
is equal to d
and what's 0.6 times 120 that's 72 right
6 times 12 is 72
6 right so that's
minus 0.6 d is equal to d
so you get 72 is equal to
1.6 d
and then
let's see 72
divided by
1.6 is equal to 45. so there we solve
the problem d
is equal to 45. 45 double scoops were
served and then we could substitute back
into the equation to figure out how many
single scoops or how many total guests
there were but this is all that we had
to figure out and we were able to using
both statements combined
to the next problem
56.
what is the value of x y
okay statement number one
they tell us that y is equal to x plus
one
statement and that's not going to tell
me what x y is i mean i could there's a
bunch of x's and a bunch of different
y's depending on which what i choose
two
they tell us y is equal to x squared
plus one once again this by itself i
mean it completely depends on which xy's
i pick right i can pick any combination
and get different values you could try
that out yourself
but i i have two equations and two
unknowns it's a little tricky because
one of them is non-linear but let's see
if we can figure it out with
substitution if y equals this and y
equals that we could set these two equal
to each other and see if we could solve
for x
so we get
x plus one that's the first one should
equal this one because they're both
equal to y
x squared plus one
let's see we can
subtract 1 from both sides and you get x
is equal to x squared
and let's see you could write
you could
you could say x
well you could divide
if we assume that x does not is is if x
does not equal zero so there's two
solutions here right
x could be equal to zero
that's completely legitimate they never
told us that x is an equal zero that
would satisfy that equation and then
what other x would satisfy x could be
equal zero or x could be equal to one
either of those are completely
legitimate answers here
right fair enough right if x is zero
this is true zero equals zero if x is
one one is equal to one squared x can't
be negative one negative one is not
equal to negative one squared so these
are the two solutions for x
and now this so right now it seems like
oh well it's a little shady but remember
we're not trying to solve for x or solve
for y we're trying to solve for x y so
maybe when we solve for y something i
don't know interesting could happen
let's solve for y if you if you assume x
is equal to 0
if x is equal to 0 what's y
well y is equal to 0 plus 1 y is equal
to 1 in this case
that's one solution
and if you put x is equal to 0 here you
also get y is equal to 1. so this is one
set of solutions and in this reality xy
is going to be equal to what
xy is going to be equal to zero
right zero times one is zero now if x is
equal to one what is y
well if x is equal to one
y is equal to one plus one y is equal to
two
well then x y is equal to two
so
using both of the equa both both of the
statements i still don't know whether x
y is equal to zero or two someone would
have to tell me that x
is not equal to zero or x is equal to
zero and only then can i really solve
this equation so the answer to this even
though we have two equations and two
unknowns because one of them was a
quadratic and had two solutions we
actually don't know what x y is so the
answer is
each that the statements together are
not sufficient or e that's interesting
because they actually kind of make you
do a little bit more work than just
eyeballing it and saying oh i have two
equations two unknowns you gotta be a
little careful when the equations are
non-linear
at least i think that's right all right
question 57 they want to know what one o
one over x
plus one over y so police sirens outside
i live in palo alto there's not normally
a high crime scene here but you never
know anyway
so one over x plus one over y
so statement number one
is
x plus y
is equal to 14.
see that doesn't well actually let me
let me try to simplify this a little bit
if i were to try to add these two what
could i do well when you add two
fractions
you have to find a common denominator an
easy common denominator for x and y is
just x y
so one over x is what over x y
what's y over x y
plus right this is the same thing as 1
over x plus and if i had x y here
what's 1 over y well that's x over x y
so that can be rewritten as
y plus x
over x y and now when you rewrite this
statement like this
then statement one looks a little
interesting they gave us the numerator
at least they haven't told us what xy is
but they told us that y plus x
or x plus y is equal to 14. so statement
one it's kind of
part of the puzzle but it's not
completely helping us let's see what
statement two tells us i suspect if this
is solvable they'll have to tell us what
xy yep that tells what xy is it tells
that xy is equal to 24.
so then we're done
right this simplifies to this and
they're telling us what this is
x plus y is 14 so it equals 14 over 24
not that we have to really solve for it
but that is equal to 7 over 12. but as
soon as we got you say oh that's that
that's that you're done you say
statement both statements together are
sufficient so c
58.
if d denotes a decimal
is d
greater than greater than or equal to
0.5 so they're d
greater than or equal to
0.5 they put a 0 here so you make sure
you notice the decimal d greater than or
equal to 0.5
statement number one
tells us
when d is rounded to the nearest tenth
the result is
0.5
when it's round to the nearest tenth the
result is 0.5 so let's see it could be
if we're this could be 0.52
and when you round it to the nearest
tenth it becomes 0.5
but on the other hand it could be 0.4
and when you round it to the nearest
tenth you also get 0.5
so since statement 1 says it could be
either one of these it really doesn't
help us know whether we're greater than
or equal to 0.5 this one is greater this
one isn't so statement 1 by itself
doesn't help statement 2
when d is rounded to the nearest integer
the result is 1. now this is interesting
if something is is rounded to the
nearest integer
it has to be well it has to be greater
than 0.5 right
i mean what what are it the smallest
number that when you round it to the
nearest integer equal to 1 is 0.5 right
so it has to be 0.5 or it has to be 0.51
because
0.4999
when you round it to the nearest integer
is going to be equal to zero
these have to be that's the only way you
can get rounded to one if you're 0.5 or
above so actually statement 2 alone is
all you need to know that d is greater
than or equal to 0.5
so that is choice b statement 2 alone is
sufficient i've realized i've run out of
time see you in the next video